[Musique]
il n'y a pas de grand salon qui réunit
tous les professionnels de proximité
donc l'idée c'est quand même de
rencontrer le grand public
des pépiniéristes d entreprise de
décoration de jardin et bien évidemment
des artisans menuisiers aussi spécialisé
dans les salons de jardin les vérandas
les paysagistes
voilà donc on a pas mal de artisans sur
le thème du jardin on à l'arc et au même
niveau que l'activité de jardin donc là
on a une cinquantaine d'artistes aussi
donc sculpteurs peintres
alors je crois qu'on va avoir évidemment
les amateurs jardin sa future je pense
qu'il va y avoir aussi des
professionnels qui vont venir et où on
me dira
et puis il ya les promeneurs évidemment
et puis il ya ceux qui aiment l'art ceux
qui sont attirés par l'art vont avoir
envie de visiter le salon
je pense que là on va attirer quand même
plusieurs univers